the other day i saw a guy in a uh
i want to be honest with you i want to
be honest the other day i saw a guy in a
leather jacket at a mexican restaurant
if you wear a leather jacket at a
mexican restaurant well you can just
stay away from me
you can stay away
from me
because i don't need that kind
halloween is over and i don't need to
see no more
of the damn
uh
pandora's box
escapees running around if you wear a
leather jacket
to a mexican restaurant you can stay
away from me
do you hear that
because i feel like some of you don't
hear if you wear a leather jacket to a
mexican restaurant you can stay away
from me because i am
[Music]
a better man than that hey theo what's
going on um i've called him once before
my name is will
um i just wanted to apologize
you know right off the bat because um i
did it
i wore a leather jacket to a mexican
restaurant last week um i took my mom
well look
willie
you don't wear a leather jacket to a
mexican restaurant
who are you brother huh
who are you abraham lincoln dude huh
tony hawk
who are you
you don't do it you took your mother i
don't care
if you taking little red riding
out
riding lady i don't care if you got i
don't care if you if goldilocks
if she's all ambient up and you got her
out that bear trap house
and you got her in there
imagine somebody see you're in there
okay somebody see you your mother the
fajita smoke goes by right
it looks like the uh you know the um the
peppers are on there just blowing
winston's
just
and then they see you and your mom you
leather jacketed up
and to the cause the perception is you
some young buck you some young drug buck
that's hammering down that's hammering
cat on this old lady
you out here hammering cat out here and
bringing her out to some
i'll tell you this if god returns when
he returns he will not you will not you
might fi you might find him at a cantina
but he
will not
be wearing leather
and you know it ask your heart
and you know it
oh
life is a salad baby and the lord
is my vinaigrette son
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one